>> MICHAEL COHEN JUST GOT OUT OF
JAIL, AND A LEGEND, ONE PERSON
ON HIS WEIGHTED JAIL, MAYBE ONLY
ONE IN AMERICA IS ROGER STONE.
TWO WEEKS WILL BE SENTENCED FOR
HIS USEFUL ADULT LIFE, HIS CRIME
SUPPORTING DONALD TRUMP, HOW
DOES HE FEEL ABOUT THAT?
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I’LL JUST GET RIGHT TO IT, I’M A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSED BY WHY, WITH
ALL THE PARDONS GOING AROUND,
EVERYONE I’VE EVER MET WHO HAS
BEEN PARDONED, YOU HAVEN’T BEEN
BY A WHITE HOUSE THAT HAS DONE A
LOT TO PUSH TERMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM AND PUT A LOT OF BAD
PEOPLE OUT OF JAIL IN THE NAME
OF HUMANITARIAN CONCERNS.
YOU’RE NOT IN THAT CAR TO GORI,
WHITE DO YOU THINK
>> I WAS HOPEFUL THAT THE MOTION
FOR A MISTRIAL IN MY PLACE WAS
BASED ON FLAGRANT AND BLATANT
AND EVEN EGREGIOUS JURY
MISCONDUCT IT WOULD’VE WON
ME A NEW TRIAL.
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT HAS BEEN
CLEAR THAT ALL DEFENDANTS ARE
ENTITLED TO A JURY THAT IS
IMPARTIAL AND INDIFFERENT, BUT
IN THIS CASE, IT IS UNDISPUTED
BOTH
, THEY ATTACKED BOTH ME AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2019’S
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTINGS, LIED
ABOUT THAT DURING JURY
SELECTION, AND THEN LATER
DELETED HER FACEBOOK PAGE TO
COVER HER TRAILS.
IN THIS CASE, LEGAL AUTHORITIES,
JUDGE ANDREW NAPOLITANO, AND
PROFESSOR JOHN TURLEY HAVE BOTH
SAID I SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO A
NEW TRIAL.
BUT THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
SO AT THIS POINT, THE JUDGES
ORDERED ME TO SURRENDER IN TWO
WEEKS, AND IT 67 YEARS
OLD WITH SOME UNDERLYING HEALTH
PROBLEMS, INCLUDING A HISTORY OF
ASTHMA, I BELIEVE WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS, IT IS ESSENTIALLY A
DEATH SENTENCE.
>> OF COURSE IT IS, THEY’VE
ALREADY DESTROYED YOUR LIFE, THE
MOST CORRUPT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROCEEDING I’VE EVER SEEN.
BOB DYLAN SHOULD BE WRITING A
SONG ABOUT YOU.
YET YOU CAN GET A PARDON,
BECAUSE YOUR CRIME WAS WORSE
THAN RATING SOMEONE, YOU
SUPPORTING TRUMP.
ARE YOU BITTER
>> I’M NOT.
I’M GLAD AFTER 16 MONTHS OF
BEING GAGGED, TO FINALLY, AT
LEAST BE ABLE TO DEFEND MYSELF.
I WASN’T PROSECUTED BECAUSE I
WAS COVERING ANYTHING UP FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
I WAS PROSECUTED BECAUSE I
REFUSED TO BEAR FALSE WITNESS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
I REFUSED TO DISSEMBLE, AS THE
PROSECUTORS WANTED TO, ABOUT
NUMEROUS PHONE CALLS BETWEEN
MYSELF AND CANDIDATE TRUMP IN
2016.
SO AT THIS JUNCTURE, I AM
PRAYING FOR JUSTICE.
I AM PRAYING FOR MERCY, I’M
GOING TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
IT’S IN GOD’S HANDS.
AFTER MEETING AND PRAYING WITH
REVEREND FRANKLIN GRAHAM, SOME
MONTHS AGO, I HAVE REACQUAINTED
MYSELF WITH MY CATHOLIC FAITH,